you've also been extremely giving and
caring and philanthropic and you have
the carmelo anthony foundation
um
why did that start
it was it was very simple
i was once one of them so for me once i
always promised and made a promise to
like my friends and just my neighborhood
and community that whenever i make it we
all make it and i'm coming back
regardless of what
i have a surprise for you um there's
actually someone here in our audience
today who wants to say thank you
personally
uh she is a science teacher in baltimore
canada
oh
[Applause]
kim crystal did you want to say anything
to carmelo um i just wanted to say thank
you um a couple years ago i had a
project on donor's shoes and you
basically donated and funded every
project in west baltimore yes um so and
mine was one and i had a class of 10
boys at the time because i was a special
education teacher and they just thought
it was like the neatest thing because
they knew who you were
um so it like meant something to them
that you
saw them or saw their need at that time
thank you kim thank you thank you kim
so much
i can i can picture those boys it there
you've brought a tangibility
and a motivational aspect to keep going
and that to me is being brought down to
the ground too like it's working and i
think you had someone in your life who
came in and sort of
pushed you yeah i had a couple people
that just came into my life i had a
coach um
he was one of the hardest coaches i've
ever had
ever he was he was a disciplinarian he
was a guy who
i didn't know what he was trying to
teach me at the time
i just felt like he was just
pointing me out or singling me out but
now that i look back at it
he was very important into
my development
you know work ethic and and
being dedicated to something and
you know
coming to practice and working hard and
and bringing people along with you and
but when i messed up
he let me know well we have another
surprise for you he's standing by on
zoom it's jim behind
me are you there
[Applause]
there you are
i mean you know you're the head
basketball coach at syracuse i mean
hello that's so important um such a high
echelon in your field uh is there
anything that you wanted to share with
carmelo today
be nice
be nice just be nice i want to clear
some up i was never really that hard on
carmelo because
it wasn't
usually you have to correct freshmen and
work with them and change them
uh
he was pretty well there when he came to
syracuse
i'd like to take credit for it but i'm
not and uh you know the rest is history
i mean he helped us win a national
championship the first year i think the
great thing with carmelo is mentally
he's always been ahead
of really everybody but as i watch you
two talk today the thing i think about
with carmelo he immediately
gave back to syracuse when he left he's
given back to every place he's been
we raised a million dollars after
carmelo's freshman year here for
make-a-wish and coaches versus cancer
because he was part of it he wanted to
be part of it and he was a leader as a
freshman
people that say he couldn't win anything
he's won three olympic gold medals he
won the national championship as a
freshman
and he's given back
every place he's been
and to me
that's what
i love melo it's not about just well the
championship was important i'll i'll
take it
you know you coached your 46 years and
you never won one you you know you're
going to appreciate the one you want
you know coach behind i'm so grateful to
you showing up today um so we could
honor both of your stories uh with
carmelo thank you coach fayeja
thank you thank you so much
and thank you kim crystal
for
bringing those 10 amazing students here
with us in that room in this room and
you're representing
them um and carmelo you're such a
trailblazer you're such a good person
thank
thank
you
carmelo anthony's highly anticipated
memoir where tomorrow's aren't promised
is out now it's incredible as are you
[Music]
you